hey guys what's up awesome news marvel just
confirmed that they are rolling cameras on
Black Panther they released a whole bunch
of details let's break it down they're shooting
the movie in South Korea if you didn't know
it's coming out in February and they have
the craziest most awesome cast ever.
It's going to be nuts.
It's the last film before infinity war.
So I'll address all the infinity war stuff
the infinity gauntlet the soul stone, but
there is a new round of the Spider-Man giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so this
picks up in the moments after Captain America
Civil War so try to address the Captain America
as well as the buggy that Avengers infinity
war stuff, but the teaser synopsis just reads
T'Challa who after the events of Captain America
Civil War returns home to the isolated, technologically
advanced African nation of Wakonda take his
place as King.
However, when an old enemy reappears on the
radar T'Challa's metal as King and Black Panther
is tested when he is drawn into a conflict
that puts the entire fate of Wakonda in the
world at risk.
So this is where we get into the villains
they tease the villas in their killmonger
and Ulysses klaw have been confirmed as villains.
They will be the only antagonists in the movie
the be a lot of other people.
There's a lot of complex politics in Wakonda
the we haven't seen it will learn about the
relationships within that nation, but you
all remember Ulysses claw from age of old
on this rock I will build my church rid him
in the it's kind of great personal cost with
billions those you he'd had passed encounters
with Wakonda he been branded for stealing
vibrating him which old Tron then turned around
and used.
To make his big drill, as well as vision is
going to be coming back to get more.
That's probably the worldwide threat like
if he gets his hands on more of that that
he's going to make weapons, it's gonna mean
trouble for the rest of the world, but testing
him on a more personal level is kill Monger
he has a much more personal relationship with
that character kill Monger is the son of someone
who was press gained into working for Ulysses
claw in the past there for his family was
exiled by Black Panthers father.
His family became dishonored outcast.
He vowed revenge against the Wakonda and people
as well as Ulysses claw went to the United
States to earn a degree from MIT Black Panther
also went to the United States to get a degree,
but he went to a different college in Berkeley
they might change that for the movie just
to give them some more Backstory together
that he becomes one of those characters to
test Black Panthers honor so Black Panther
will face very big challenges from people
like Ulysses claw and very personal challenges
to his reign of people like kill Monger.
So everybody wants to take a shot at the King
and now he's King as the synopsis implies
right after Civil War he's affectively King.
So yes to go back and deal with all that now,
the movie is coming out February 2018.
So you have to imagine that it's a couple
years after the end of Captain America Civil
War was already been back in Wakonda for little
while he may have even been bankrolling Captain
America's secret Avengers.
That's what I'm in a column for now but he
doesn't have the shield is not using the title,
so technically he's not Captain America anymore.
That will change till infinity war, but in
the way were getting and Iron Man appearance
during Spider-Man we might see some Captain
America buggy stuff during the Black Panther
movie.
But they been very very minor characters because
it just so much rich history in the Black
Panther comics that Marvel hasn't touched
yet the gonna need to spend most of the time
setting that up, you can see how they're doing
more crossovers now just a sort of juice up
the pitch of a movie like hey come see Black
Panther and see that other character that
you really really like Captain America, so
that's kind of the way that they're sweetening
the pot to get people to go see.
Spider-Man because we know you love, Iron
Man so were going to put them in this movie,
so they get a lot of other people that would
otherwise care about the Spider-Man movie.
The other really important thing to consider
is that Black Panther is coming out just a
couple months before Avengers infinity war.
So the end of that movie will lead directly
into the opening moments of infinity war.
Meaning that, because we know buggy is coming
back for infinity war he'll have to be at
least some Captain America storyline stuff
happening that they could totally push that
to post credit status.
Like they don't accept to hijack any of the
movie if they don't want to for that.
If you don't know anything about the rest
of the cast, they just have like the murderers
row of talent.
They have Martin Freeman who's playing Everett
Ross also from Captain America Civil War he
sort of the government liaison.
It deals with the Wakonda nation Forest Whitaker's
playing a character from the comics is sort
of like the advisor to the previous Black
Panther.
He becomes the wise master that helps advise
Black Panther as he tries to learn how to
be king the Danai Gurira and Lupita N'yongo
are both playing Dora Milaje there going to
be so bad ass like special forces military
spec ops just the most bad ass soldiers in
full-blown tech and vibrating him gear that
you could possibly imagine.
That's why that black widow standoff in Civil
War was so funny Black Panther himself just
chuckles oh I would love to see this, but
we don't have time will undulate is it's attending
is that the really think you can find out
assesses a considerable to the world 70 years
to find pharmacy so you will totally get to
see Dora Milaje bro down during Black Panther.
The other big comic book character is a man
a he's another antagonists the tries to take
Black Panthers throne.
He started out as one of their most fierce
warriors then plotted it to failed and was
exiled and just continued to harass them over
time just became this big recurring villain
here something is really cool to for those
you that are holding out hope for Captain
America stuff during the movie actual Captain
America stuff.
A lot of these villains were also taken down
by Captain America himself but I think it
is going to be any victory to be had in the
film it will be Black Panthers victory is
his film, it's like his first big outing in
the marvel universe it's not in someone else's
film.
So all hail the King of the Marvel universe.
Everybody wants his vibrating him, it's what
makes him richer than Tony Stark who we can
probably say he is one of if not the richest
person in the marvel universe.
That's why he doesn't bat an eyelash when
it comes to spending and making toys for the
avengers funding all that stuff, so Black
Panther himself could also fund his own team
Avengers which is why I think he's secretly
helping out Captain America on the DL while
he's hiding out from the government because
he still in outlaws the end of Captain America
Civil War for those of you asking about the
infinity stones.
What is the soul stone shows up in Black Panther.
The only reason that I don't think that is
going to show up during Black Panther in it
could is just because the reality stone was
stored on earth in they said that no two gems
should be kept in the same place so that would
mean only one gem on earth at a time and we
have the mind stone envision right now.
Meaning that the reality gem is still with
the collector in the nova court got the power
stone, so that doesn't really address the
more mystical aspects of Black Panthers abilities
the panther totem it's self it seems like
so far, based on what they told us that the
marvel universe flows from a more technological
origin rather than a mystical metahuman one,
even though there are people with powers most
of them are obtained either through the infinity
stones or through spider bites, but even people
like the vulture have a more technological
appearance is just the influence of Iron Man
and the success of that movie and that franchise,
Robert Downey Junior on the rest of the Marvel
universe.
All of the aesthetics flow from him.
So it seems like most of Black Panthers abilities
flow from technological sources and I do think
the weave in some of the mysticism to the
he typically eats herbs that gives him his
physical abilities that makes him just as
strong if not stronger than Captain America
that's not the only thing that makes him a
bad ass but he also has access to the memories
of all the previous Black Panther.
So that's what they say King of the dead Black
Panther they might address that during the
movie.
But they tend to brush over a lot of the really
weird stuff.
But there was that line and Captain America
Civil War where he explained that death was
not the end to black widow after his father
had died #in my culture did you some of a
stepping off point to reach out with both
hands.
Bust sacrament that he doing to the green
about the run forever.
Sounds very peaceful.
My father thought.
So, so take that as you will.
But I think that's them just acknowledging
the more mystical aspects of the Black Panther
comics so it's going to be great.
They have Ryan Kugler he's a great director
did an awesome job with creed.
The funny thing about creed is that the lead
actress is actually playing Valkyrie in Thor
Ragnarok was like all those people from creed
just came into the marvel universe in different
places and by the way that actually includes
Sylvester Stallone here who has a really small
part and guardians of the galaxy to even Michael
B Jordan had the sickest Fox fantastic four
burn at comic con.
He's like they got I'm finally in the good
marvel universe.
It was such an offhanded comment, but it caught
me by surprise like all man.
He said that in front of all those people
on camera, but seriously though.
A lot of you have asked me if Marvel will
get the rights to fantastic four back it's
totally possible.
I think that they would try to use them in
a big avengers film is like minor characters
and then try to weave them out in the something
bigger, but the only people that have said
anything about this are the directors who
don't have any control over those characters
are not part of those discussions.
So where anything about Fox characters coming
back to Marvel.
I will totally do a video about it we can
freak out.
Let me know what you guys most excited for
in the Black Panther movie of the be a lot
of people who just want to see how it connects
to infinity war because that would be like
our first teased, but I am expecting post
credits scenes from other movies like Thor
Ragnarok sort of tea that up to, so the be
a lot of infinity war stuff happening in the
background through these other films, so everybody
freak out as can be great was can happen next
is there is some more infinity war that I
want to post this week there's some behind-the-scenes
Spider-Man stuff they been teasing a lot of
stuff from the other actors.
Everyone's been saying a lot of things.
So I will do new video sometime this weekend
but I have some new Star Wars episode eight.
There's new game of thrones all kinds of Marvel
and DC stuff.
But I will say congratulations to the new
Spider-Man giveaway winner Adam Baker please
private message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll just announce the winner the next
time I post a Marvel video while you guys
wait for that next video you can click here
to learn all about the brand-new avengers
Square Enix games it's going to be crazy and
you can click here to listen to Tom Holland
talk about the new Spider-Man Suit.
Thank you so much watching every five I'll
see you the next video!